give me because obviously you were part
of the the rap Olympics right which were
for people who don't know very pivotal
to a lot of people's careers but I mean
specifically we always hear you know
Eminem is synonymous with rap Olympics
and his kind of a part of his story
um and you were a part of his team when
you did the rap Olympics right
who'd you guys go against was it I mean
I believe it was Project blow out of La
uh yep I believe they were the only ones
that showed up there was a long roster
of teams that were supposed to be there
from like every popular rap group that
was out Fuji's was supposed to have a
team it was you know different
Representatives yeah yeah and nobody
showed up everybody on my team was a
master in freestyling off the head right
you know juice Eminem myself Wordsworth
Quest the Mad lad like sit in the room
with us and you [__] get blown even
Craig G was out there hanging out with
us like staying with us and things like
that so but it was a big moment man I
was gonna say like for you like
I just remember Eminem being a real
backpack rapper I guess back then if you
knew about him you knew about him but he
was definitively like an underground guy
like he was on sound bombing too he did
the any man record he obviously bad bad
versus evil with him and um or Batman
and Royce and he was definitely like
um you know [__] I wouldn't say no
different but like there was guys like
him classified there was guys like in
that kind of like you know the white boy
rapper who could spit like crazy and
then it was just like a switch got
flipped and it's the Dr Dre switch of
course but like
how crazy was that for you to kind of
see appear
just go from like hey I'm battling with
this dude in the cipher and he's doing
the MTV VMAs and he's an absolute
Superstar and it's not like Eminem was
like Eminem was like a lyrical rapper
yeah like he was like
lyrical Miracle spiritual dude so like
you know if you heard his records prior
to him getting to a Dre you would never
think like he was even capable of making
crossover records I always believed it
because but his talent levels are so
crazy what was that like being around
Ant-Man
is like I knew he was destined I knew
because his talent blew everyone away
you know we had a big mutual respect for
what we both were able to do now
I knew at any moment something was gonna
happen and he was really the actual
factual truth you know I always me when
when I credit anyone or anybody in the
industry I base everything off skills
first you know I mean most important
that's how he is for me and skills first
right I don't care about nothing else he
had the skills to take it there you know
what I mean so but
you know I was around several artists
and I seen them blow up you know I seen
most in quality I've seen that said you
know as far as my peers are concerned
I've seen them take off I've seen them
take off I've seen so many of us and
then all it did was give me hope and it
showed me that it's possible to see the
level that I am got into I'm like I'm
next I'm coming and even to this day
where I've never I've never had a
situation I've never had a record deal
I've never had any of that but I always
knew that if I stay in it to win it and
I stay consistent my day is gonna
eventually come and that's everybody's
thing as long as you put in the work you
will have eventually reached that
[__] status that way even if I
had to do it myself and which I did but
this is not even the end this I feel
like this is not even the beginning well
you got a new album uh with a hope like
a uh I'm sorry
filming in on the producer's name it's
Mateo guess my dude Mateo guests
handling all the all the album The hope
he did he did the entire production you
know Mateo guess it's from Framingham
Massachusetts he been my close friend
for you know since he was a teenager you
know I would hang out with him in the
studio him the entire Havoc house from
out there you know I met him through my
other good friend Jackson so you know we
just Mateo guess was like besides myself
meant he's probably the most dedicated
person to hip-hop I ever met where
nothing else matters but hip-hop and him
pursuing hip-hop and being a producer
and living his life according to hip-hop
so I mean he came into a situation where
financial situation where he's like yo
we can do us we can make an album right
now push it and he gave me a call and we
decided to work on an entire album I've
never done an entire album with anyone
besides myself being the producer
producing the entire album right you
know but like I said he was my brother I
was happy to do it we were already
working for years besides that he's
always produced something on my projects
we've always hung out we've always just
been friends if that's all we had you
know but he produced this whole album he
definitely crushed it all the Beats you
know I actually got everything that I
wanted you know we we worked it slowly
because I always wanted to make sure I
had the right material but at the end of
the day we had that polish you know
finished product that was I was
definitely like proud of I was gonna say
for you to be a part of so many eras
right where people will buy vinyl people
buy a CD and now we got the streaming
era of me music Tick Tock era of music
it's a lot more different is it harder
to keep adjusting when it's like it
feels like everyone's attention span is
getting shorter and shorter I mean you
have a built-in fan base like that's
going to support like no matter what but
how are you evolving with just the
business that's evolving from day to day
you know evolve or dissolve yeah like I
said I make sure I stay in tune right
I'm not a trend follow-up right but I
will follow what's needed to push what
I'm doing right you know I might not be
into certain things or actually even
enjoy them but I know if they're
necessary yes I'm going to apply along
with them and do and evolve as times
evolving I'm not changing my style for
nobody and [__] like that I mean I don't
think I think it would be crazy for you
to do that because your fans they expect
they expect that crazy [__] you know I
mean but I'm also in my my opinion I'm
one of the most versatile artists ever
because I switched so many different
Lanes you know I go from Spanish
Spanglish reggae I do [__] nasty [__]
like 2 Live Crew I do extremely creative
I do massive punchline songs so you know
you can't really box me as an artist I
can do the commercial [__] all day long
and I could give you the raws hip-hop
you could imagine yo I'm not tripping
you had a record on did you you have a
record on one of the Grand Theft Autos
no no okay maybe I'm tripping you know
what maybe I'm confused because you were
on game for a little bit yeah I did a
single with game the polo Rican that was
chassis I remember they had uh they had
some [__] they had the Roy [__] after
they had the Aguilar to cook Cookie
Monster they had the blase single shout
out John schuck the two man shot shacky
Green Man shacky green is that he's a
wild guy that's that dope store in Vegas
hip hopsite.com which was a [__] sick
ass stores shout out to Pizzo is the man
I did a lot of stuff with Piezo man I
never even met him personally really I
mean just super nice guy yeah yeah but I
just remember like uh when I was a kid
like when I went to Vegas my parents
were like what do you want to do I was
like there's a store if you could take
wow I'll do you man 36. oh wow that's
what's up my kids are older than you man
everyone bought a big hour I wouldn't
have bought a big L t-shirt from that
store hip hopsite.com damn I even did
promos for them like um you know songs
and commercials to advertise this site
man but Piezo was a good dude man like
we did a lot of stuff together you know
as far as pushing my albums and things
like that they definitely supported me